we now go to las vegas efforts to get
out of the coronavirus pandemic today is
the deadline for thousands of
hospitality and casino workers to show
proof of vaccination that deadline is
for all mgm resorts properties in the
westgate other properties have similar
policies already in place hector mejia
live this afternoon at the west gate
with the story hector good afternoon
hey there things are quite busy at this
hour here at the westgate the new policy
applies to all non-union workers unless
they provide a medical or a religious
exemption the westgate expects the vast
majority of those employees to already
be fully vaccinated by this weekend
gordon prouty vp of public and community
relations at westgate las vegas talked
with us about the october 15 deadline we
respect the decision making process of
all of our team members but we've lost
team members and one of the common
threads there was that none of them had
been vaccinated there was a story of a
team member who
the team member and their spouse both
passed away and left seven kids without
parents he says it's necessary in order
to put an end to the pandemic we're not
going to put an end to kovit i mean you
know it's going to be there but you've
got to keep people safe and in order to
do that we just feel you have to do
everything possible you know we were the
first property to put the mass mandate
back in place and we feel the vaccine
it's been proven if you follow the
science the vaccine will keep you safe
you know you may still get covey but
you'll survive october 15th is also the
deadline for all mgm resorts properties
the vaccine mandate there only applies
to salaried as well as new employees
hired after august 30th mandatory
testing is still in effect for
pre-existing hourly employees who don't
want to get the vaccine i reached out to
mgm resorts for a written statement they
plan to release numbers next week
in a written statement the culinary
union said employees hospitality workers
have had access to the kovic 19 vaccine
since march of this year the union the
union also went on to say that the
vaccine is the best way to not only save
lives but also the hospitality industry
reporting live from the west gate hector
mejia live local now